ما يكرهه المسلمون نحن نكره طوابير طويلة
في DMV والتي تثير استياءنا عندما
يتصل بنا جامعو الفواتير أثناء العشاء ، لا أحد
يحب
أن الكثير منا
لا يحب موسيقى الريف.
أعتقد أنه ممثل كوميدي
أمريكي مسلم. الاختلافات التي يمكنني أن
أمزح حول مجتمعي ، يمكنني أن أسخر
من المسلمين ، وسأسخر من المسلمين
، وما أقصده أنا أسخر من
حقيقة أننا نفرط في استخدام مصطلح إن شاء الله
الذي يعني الله.  إن شاء حتى
الوضع لا يهتم الله به ،
أعني أنني كنت مطعمًا في الأردن ،
سألت النادل أين الحمام الذي
يذهب إليه هناك ، أذهب ،
سأعود فورًا يشفي إن شاء الله ، أنا مثل ما
حدث في حمامك  أنني بحاجة إلى حماية الله ،
وسأسخر مما
يفعله المسلمون حيال التأخر ، وفي
الشرق الأوسط يدخنون السجائر
ويتشاجرون على الشيك الذي أستخدمه بهدوء
قدر الإمكان لأكون شافيًا
لمجتمعي الذي يمر
بأوقات عصيبة لتمكينهم.  آمل ت  من خلال
الكوميديا ولتدمير بعض ال
عصب والكراهية اللذين يحدثان لنا بج
ل الناس يضحكون عليه ، أعتقد أن
كرة الضحك على ال
شياء التي تخيفك تأخذ قوتهم مهمة جدًا.